47 years ago, on a warm summer's night in Melbourne, Susan Bartlett and Suzanne Armstrong were stabbed to death in their home in Easy Street, Collingwood. Suzanne's 16-month-old son was asleep in his cot at the time. To this day, the Easy Street murders is still one of Australia's most confronting cold cases. No one has ever been charged, and critical questions remain unanswered. Journalist Helen Thomas has been investigating Susan and Suzanne's deaths for more than a decade, initially for the Australian Broadcasting Corporation's background briefing program and then for her book, Murder on Easy Street. Now Helen has delved into the case again for a brand new original podcast made for Casefile
47年前，在一个温暖的夏夜，苏珊·巴特利特（Susan Bartlett）和苏珊娜·阿姆斯特朗（Suzanne Armstrong）在她们位于科林伍德（Collingwood）易街（Easy Street）的家中被刺身亡。当时，苏珊娜16个月大的儿子正在婴儿床里熟睡。时至今日，“易街谋杀案”仍是澳大利亚最令人震惊的悬案之一。从未有人因此被起诉，关键问题也依然悬而未决。记者海伦·托马斯（Helen Thomas）对苏珊和苏珊娜的死因进行了十多年的调查，最初是为澳大利亚广播公司的《背景简报》（Background Briefing）节目，后来是为了她的书《易街谋杀案》（Murder on Easy Street）。现在，海伦为Casefile制作的一档全新原创播客再次深入调查了这起案件。
Presents. Search Casefile Presents The Easy Street Murders wherever you get your podcasts. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. 74-year-old Elizabeth Tursky faced a dilemma. She had one day left to decide whether or not to put an offer in for a house, but she couldn't make up her mind. Someone recommended that
Casefile Presents出品。请在您收听播客的任何平台搜索《Casefile Presents: The Easy Street Murders》。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用内或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。74岁的伊丽莎白·特斯基（Elizabeth Tursky）面临一个两难境地。她只剩下一天时间来决定是否要对一栋房子出价，但她拿不定主意。有人建议……
Elizabeth speak with a spiritualist who was known to have excellent powers as they might be able to offer some guidance. Seeing no harm in getting their advice, Elizabeth visited the Spiritualist, taking her 12-year-old granddaughter, Alma, as company. Elizabeth handed the Spiritualist papers pertaining to the property. The Spiritualist pressed the papers against her forehead and closed her eyes. After a moment of quiet contemplation, she advised Elizabeth not to make the purchase. As long as she was there, Elizabeth thought of something else she'd like guidance on. Alma's mother had died seven years prior from a kidney disorder. Since then, the young girl had been a much-loved companion to Elizabeth,
伊丽莎白去咨询一位以拥有卓越能力而闻名的灵媒，因为对方或许能提供一些指导。伊丽莎白觉得寻求建议并无坏处，于是带着她12岁的孙女阿尔玛（Alma）一同前往。伊丽莎白将有关房产的文件交给了灵媒。灵媒将文件按在额头上，闭上了眼睛。经过片刻的静默沉思，她建议伊丽莎白不要购买。既然来了，伊丽莎白又想到了另一件她想寻求指导的事情。阿尔玛的母亲七年前因肾脏疾病去世。从那时起，这个小女孩就成了伊丽莎白深爱的伴侣，
but their time together was coming to an end. Alma's father lived in the regional Victorian town of Mafra, 220 kilometres away from Elizabeth's home in Melbourne. Plans were underway to send Alma and her younger sister Viola to Mafra so their family could reunite. Elizabeth wasn't against the idea, but the thought of Alma leaving filled her with sadness. She asked the spiritualist if Alma went to Mafra, would she ever come back? The spiritualist closed her eyes and had a think. No, she replied. Back at school, Alma told her friends about the visit. They could tell that she was troubled by it. With a sad face, Alma said the spiritualist told her that she'd die within three months. Alma's friends dismissed the omen, finding it somewhat funny.
但她们在一起的时光即将结束。阿尔玛的父亲住在距离伊丽莎白墨尔本家中220公里外的维多利亚州马弗拉（Mafra）镇。他们正在计划将阿尔玛和她年幼的妹妹维奥拉（Viola）送到马弗拉，以便一家团聚。伊丽莎白并不反对这个想法，但想到阿尔玛要离开，她心中充满了悲伤。她问灵媒，如果阿尔玛去了马弗拉，她还会回来吗？灵媒闭上眼睛思考了一会儿。她回答说：“不会。”回到学校后，阿尔玛把这次访问告诉了朋友们。她们看得出她为此感到困扰。阿尔玛面带愁容地说，灵媒告诉她，她会在三个月内死去。阿尔玛的朋友们不以为意，觉得这有点好笑。
But when Elizabeth Tershki was later informed of this, she was confused. She didn't recall the spiritualist giving any such premonition. Elizabeth wondered, was it a harmless fib Alma told to get attention from her schoolmates, or was it indicative of an unnerving feeling the young girl sensed within herself? The following month of December 1921, Melbourne was abuzz with anticipation for the coming new year. Yet, as night fell on Friday December 30, things were quiet and sombre at a flat on Collins Street. Several members of the Tershki family and their loved ones had gathered inside, unable to sleep. Elizabeth Tershki was among them, sitting in the parlour with a light on and the front
但当伊丽莎白·特斯基后来得知此事时，她感到很困惑。她不记得灵媒曾给出过这样的预言。伊丽莎白心想，这到底是阿尔玛为了博取同学关注而编造的无伤大雅的谎言，还是这个小女孩内心深处某种不安感的体现？1921年12月的下一个月，墨尔本正沉浸在对新年的期待中。然而，12月30日星期五夜幕降临，科林斯街（Collins Street）的一间公寓里却显得安静而阴郁。特斯基家族的几位成员和他们的亲人聚集在里面，无法入睡。伊丽莎白·特斯基也在其中，她坐在客厅里，开着灯，前……
door unlocked. Minutes after midnight, the door opened. Elizabeth stiffened in anticipation as two police officers walked through the doorway. With bated breath, she asked, Hours earlier, Alma Tursky had been sent on an errand. Her uncle John worked at a butcher's shop on Swanston Street, a bustling store-lined thoroughfare in the heart of Melbourne's CBD. The shop, named Benetton-Walkox, was just over two kilometres from Alma's grandmother's home in the city-fringed suburb of Jolimont. Alma was to visit the butcher shop, pick up a parcel of meat, and then drop it at her aunt's flat on nearby Collins Street
门没锁。午夜过后几分钟，门开了。伊丽莎白满怀期待地紧绷着身体，两名警察走进了门口。她屏住呼吸问道。几个小时前，阿尔玛·特斯基被派去跑腿。她的叔叔约翰（John）在斯旺斯顿街（Swanston Street）的一家肉铺工作，那是一条位于墨尔本中央商务区中心地带、商店林立的繁忙大道。这家名为“贝内顿-沃尔科克斯”（Benetton-Walkox）的商店距离阿尔玛祖母位于城市边缘郊区乔利蒙特（Jolimont）的家只有两公里多。阿尔玛要去肉铺取一包肉，然后送到附近科林斯街她姑姑的公寓，
before returning home. The weekly task was usually carried out by other family members, but they were unavailable and Alma was home for the school holidays, so she was happy to do it. Although Alma hadn't run this errand before, she had travelled into the city multiple times and was familiar with the area. All up, the trip was expected to take no longer than two hours. Alma was given money for a tram fare, but she decided to walk instead. It was a pleasant day, and with plenty of other people moving about and busy traffic passing by, she felt safe to do so. Alma took the scenic route through the Fitzroy and Treasury Gardens, arriving at Bennett
然后再回家。这项每周一次的任务通常由其他家庭成员完成，但他们当时没空，而阿尔玛正好放寒假在家，所以她很乐意去做。虽然阿尔玛以前没跑过这趟腿，但她多次进城，对该地区很熟悉。总的来说，这趟行程预计不会超过两个小时。阿尔玛拿了坐电车的钱，但她决定步行。那天天气很好，路上行人众多，交通繁忙，她觉得步行很安全。阿尔玛走了风景优美的路线，穿过菲茨罗伊花园（Fitzroy Gardens）和财政花园（Treasury Gardens），在下午1点多一点到达了贝内特……
and Wilcox shortly after 1pm. Alma's Uncle John wasn't there, so she spoke to the cashier instead, who gave her the parcel of sausages and corned beef. By the time Alma left for her aunt's flat on Collins Street, it was around 1.30. The flat was just a short walk away, but Alma never showed up. When she didn't return to Jollymont either, her family grew concerned. They headed out to trace Alma's steps, but she was nowhere to be found. While searching the city, Alma's uncle John spoke to a police officer, who suggested that Alma might have taken a tram to the beach to enjoy the nice weather. But Alma's family weren't convinced. She hadn't been given enough money for a tram ticket that far.
和威尔科克斯（Wilcox）肉铺。阿尔玛的叔叔约翰不在，所以她和收银员说了话，收银员给了她一包香肠和咸牛肉。阿尔玛出发前往科林斯街姑姑公寓时，大约是1点30分。公寓离那儿只有很短的步行路程，但阿尔玛却一直没出现。当她也没有回到乔利蒙特时，她的家人开始担心起来。他们出发去寻找阿尔玛的踪迹，但她却不见踪影。在城里搜寻时，阿尔玛的叔叔约翰向一名警察询问，警察建议阿尔玛可能坐电车去海边享受好天气了。但阿尔玛的家人并不相信。她拿的钱不够买那么远的车票。
The officer headed back to the station where calls were made to nearby hospitals. Alma hadn't wound up at any of them. Her loved ones were told to return to the Collins Street flat in case Elmer had finally appeared there. As night time descended with no sign of Elmer, her Uncle John headed to Victoria Police Headquarters on Russell Street to formally report his nieces missing. He was assured that a description of Alma would be sent to other stations so that all officers would be on the lookout for the 12-year-old. The slightly built Alma was 4 foot 10 inches tall with freckles and long golden red hair. She was wearing her school uniform, which consisted of a box pleated navy blue dress with a white blouse underneath, a white leghorn hat,
警察回到警局，拨打了附近医院的电话。阿尔玛并没有出现在任何一家医院。她的亲人们被告知回到科林斯街的公寓，以防阿尔玛最终出现在那里。夜幕降临，仍不见阿尔玛的踪影，她的叔叔约翰前往位于罗素街（Russell Street）的维多利亚州警察总部，正式报告侄女失踪。他得到保证，阿尔玛的描述将被发送到其他警局，以便所有警官都能留意这位12岁的女孩。身材瘦小的阿尔玛身高4英尺10英寸，长着雀斑，留着一头金红色的长发。她穿着校服，包括一件海军蓝色的箱褶连衣裙，里面穿着白色衬衫，戴着一顶白色利古里亚草帽，
black stockings, and black shoes. Even though it was the school holidays, this was the nicest outfit Alma owned for a trip into the city. The police also made another round of calls to nearby hospitals. Alma still hadn't been admitted to any of them. When told to return to their homes and not to worry, Alma's family couldn't help but feel like the police were treating the situation too casually. Alma was intelligent, reliable, and well behaved. She wasn't the type to get up to mischief. Respecting her elders was a large part of Alma's personality, and she'd never intentionally do something to cause others to worry. She'd recently returned home early from her school's late-night
穿着黑色长袜和黑色鞋子。尽管是在放寒假，但这却是阿尔玛进城时穿的最好的一套衣服。警方还对附近医院进行了新一轮的电话询问。阿尔玛仍然没有被送进任何一家医院。当被告知回家不必担心时，阿尔玛的家人不禁觉得警方处理此事过于随意。阿尔玛聪明、可靠、举止端庄。她不是那种会惹是生非的孩子。尊重长辈是阿尔玛性格中很重要的一部分，她绝不会故意做任何让别人担心的事情。她最近刚从学校的深夜……
end-of-year celebrations just to give her grandmother peace of mind. In the 1920s, Australian children were raised conservatively. As a result, Alma was incredibly naive and modest. Menstruation, sex and other coming of age experiences were taboo subjects she knew little about, if anything at all. Alma couldn't even bring herself to talk to the boys at her school, let alone strangers. There was no reason to believe that she was disobeying her grandmother to push boundaries. Alma lived her life doing for others. In a school essay titled, Duty First, she wrote, We should always do our duty to everybody before we do anything. Duty means kindness, goodness, helpfulness, and to do anything to please others. A duty embraces a multitude of things. The following are duties concerning our lives. Household duties, garden duties, to help people,
年终庆祝活动中提前回家，只是为了让祖母放心。在20世纪20年代，澳大利亚的孩子们接受的是保守的教育。因此，阿尔玛非常天真、谦逊。月经、性以及其他成年礼般的经历对她来说都是禁忌话题，她几乎一无所知。阿尔玛甚至无法与学校里的男生交谈，更不用说陌生人了。没有理由相信她会为了挑战底线而违抗祖母。阿尔玛的生活就是为他人服务。在一篇题为《责任第一》的学校作文中，她写道：“我们应该在做任何事之前，始终对每个人尽到我们的责任。责任意味着善良、美好、乐于助人，以及做任何让别人高兴的事。责任包含许多事情。以下是关于我们生活的责任：家庭责任、园艺责任、帮助他人、
school duties, to love, honour and obey your parents and relations and teachers. This demonstrated Alma's desire to always do what she was told and never leave anyone waiting by deviating from her given task. As Elizabeth Tershki described, I had always been very strict with my granddaughter. We had all taken particular pains to keep her mind free from all sordid and frivolous matters. Her disposition was just all sweetness. In her own home, she was happiness itself. For instance, she might be at a tea party with her aunts and myself, and after we had finished the meal, we would miss Alma. On investigating, we would find that she had actually been washing up the dishes by herself. There was no need for any of us, or even for her, to worry.
学校责任、爱、尊重并服从你的父母、亲戚和老师。”这表明了阿尔玛总是想听从吩咐，绝不因偏离既定任务而让任何人等待的愿望。正如伊丽莎白·特斯基所描述的那样：“我一直对我的孙女非常严格。我们都特别费心，让她的思想远离一切肮脏和轻浮的事物。她的性格简直是甜美至极。在家里，她本身就是快乐的化身。例如，她可能和她的姑姑们以及我在一起喝下午茶，当我们吃完饭后，我们会发现阿尔玛不见了。调查后，我们会发现她其实一直在独自洗碗。我们任何人，甚至她自己，都不需要担心。”
There was no need for any of us, or even for her, to worry. For Alma's family, her unexplained absence meant that something terrible must have happened. At the Collins Street flat, Elizabeth waited in the parlor in the hopes her granddaughter would wander in safe and sound. By midnight, four hours had passed since Alma was reported missing. By midnight, four hours had passed since Alma was reported missing. Two police officers soon pushed through the flat's unlocked front door. Elizabeth immediately quizzed them about her granddaughter, but the officers were confused. It was part of their job to check premises where lights were on inside and the doors appeared to be unlocked. They were just carrying out their regular duties. Although their patch encompassed the areas relevant to Alma Tershki's disappearance,
我们任何人，甚至她自己，都不需要担心。对于阿尔玛的家人来说，她无法解释的失踪意味着一定发生了可怕的事情。在科林斯街的公寓里，伊丽莎白坐在客厅里，希望她的孙女能平安归来。到午夜时分，距离阿尔玛被报告失踪已经过去了四个小时。到午夜时分，距离阿尔玛被报告失踪已经过去了四个小时。两名警察很快推开了公寓没锁的前门。伊丽莎白立即询问他们关于她孙女的情况，但警察们感到困惑。检查灯亮着且门似乎没锁的场所是他们工作的一部分。他们只是在履行日常职责。虽然他们的巡逻区域涵盖了与阿尔玛·特斯基失踪相关的区域，
they hadn't been informed of the matter. By the following morning of Saturday December 31, 1921, there still hadn't been any sign of Alma. As Melbourne stirred in preparation for New Year's Eve, Henry Errington roamed the streets with his 11-year-old daughter. The pair were scavenging for glass bottles to cash in for recycling. They'd already made decent pickings around the city's bustling bar district in the east, having so far filled two sacks. The duo made their way to the Eastern Market, a flower and retail market between Little Collins and Burke Streets. The surrounding streets and laneways consisted of drinkeries, betting shops, and brothels, and at night, the area was a hotbed of wild antics and bad behaviour. Henry knew there'd be plenty of bottles scattered about
但他们并没有被告知此事。到了1921年12月31日星期六的第二天早上，依然没有任何阿尔玛的踪迹。当墨尔本在为除夕夜做准备时，亨利·埃林顿（Henry Errington）带着他11岁的女儿在街上游荡。两人正在搜寻玻璃瓶，以便换取回收现金。他们在城里东部繁忙的酒吧区周围已经有了不错的收获，到目前为止装满了两个麻袋。这对父女前往东部市场（Eastern Market），这是一个位于小科林斯街（Little Collins Street）和伯克街（Burke Street）之间的花卉和零售市场。周围的街道和小巷里挤满了酒馆、博彩店和妓院，到了晚上，这里是狂野举动和不良行为的温床。亨利知道会有很多瓶子散落在……
the footpaths, gutters, and drains in the early morning aftermath. The father and daughter turned down Little Collins Street, a one-way lane of boutique shops, bars and hotels that ran parallel to the wider Collins Street. Sandwiched between a barbershop and hardware store was a narrow alleyway called Gunn Alley. A nearby clock tower chimed 6am as Henry made his way into Gunn Alley while his young daughter trailed further behind. It was a secluded space. One side was framed by a two-storey brick wall while a tall corrugated iron and wood fence flanked the other. With no source of light, Gunn Alley was perpetually dark. A few metres in, the alley took a sharp turn that led behind the barbershop and reached a dead end.
人行道、排水沟和下水道里，那是清晨的残余。这对父女转入小科林斯街，这是一条与较宽的科林斯街平行的单行道，两旁是精品店、酒吧和酒店。在一家理发店和一家五金店之间，有一条狭窄的小巷，名叫冈恩巷（Gunn Alley）。附近钟楼敲响了早上6点的钟声，亨利走进了冈恩巷，而他年幼的女儿则落在后面。这是一个僻静的空间。一侧是两层高的砖墙，另一侧则是一道高高的波纹铁和木栅栏。由于没有光源，冈恩巷终年黑暗。往里走几米，小巷急转弯，绕到理发店后面，变成了一条死胡同。
Henry Errington made the turn and paused. The naked body of Alma Tursky was lying face up on the brick pavement. Her legs were bent with one on top of the other. Bruises covered her right eye, shoulder, thigh, jaw, and throat. Henry turned and stopped his daughter from witnessing the horrific sight before rushing to a nearby store to phone the police. Investigators determined that Alma had sustained a heavy blow to her right eye, but the cause of her death was ruled asphyxiation by manual strangulation. This implied that her murder was opportunistic, as the killer hadn't been prepared with a weapon. Alma's body showed signs of sexual assault, yet no foreign fluids were detected. A watery stain
亨利·埃林顿转过弯，停下了脚步。阿尔玛·特斯基赤裸的尸体面朝上躺在砖砌的人行道上。她的双腿弯曲，一条压在另一条上面。她的右眼、肩膀、大腿、下巴和喉咙上布满了淤青。亨利转过身，阻止女儿目睹这恐怖的一幕，然后冲到附近的一家商店打电话报警。调查人员确定阿尔玛的右眼受到了重击，但她的死因被裁定为手动勒颈导致的窒息。这意味着她的谋杀是机会主义的，因为凶手并没有准备武器。阿尔玛的尸体显示出性侵犯的迹象，但没有检测到外来体液。一条水渍……
running down Alma's thigh indicated that her killer had cleaned her body post-assault. It was determined that Alma had been dead for several hours before her body was found. Gun alley showed no signs of a struggle, nor was there anything under Alma's fingernails to indicate she'd put up a fight. The killer hadn't left anything behind and Alma's clothing was missing. Therefore, detectives surmised the bulk of the attack must have occurred elsewhere. Alma had likely been killed the previous day before being dumped in the alley later that night. The area was scoured for clues. Police wondered whether the killer could have tried to force Alma's body down a nearby barrel drain and into the wide pipes 12 feet below, as her head was
顺着阿尔玛的大腿流下，表明凶手在袭击后清洗了她的尸体。经确定，阿尔玛在尸体被发现前已经死亡数小时。冈恩巷没有打斗的迹象，阿尔玛的指甲下也没有任何东西表明她曾进行过反抗。凶手没有留下任何东西，阿尔玛的衣服也不见了。因此，侦探们推测袭击的大部分过程一定发生在别处。阿尔玛很可能在前一天就被杀害，然后在那天晚些时候被抛尸在小巷里。警方对该地区进行了搜查以寻找线索。警方怀疑凶手是否曾试图将阿尔玛的尸体塞进附近的一个桶状排水沟，并推入12英尺下方的宽大管道中，因为她的头部……
found partially resting on it. The drains were checked, but nothing of interest was found. Even if evidence had been discarded down there, the chances of recovering it now were slim. The flowing water would have swept it through the pipes under the city and beyond. Surrounding bins, shops, residents, and rooftops were also checked for clues, but the search came up dry. Police turned their attention to potential witnesses. A sex worker told them that she'd been in Gun Alley just before 1am. She didn't see Alma's body or anyone suspicious. As this woman had a reliable reputation with authorities, police determined that Alma's body had been dumped some time after 1 o'clock.
被发现部分靠在上面。排水沟经过了检查，但没有发现任何有价值的东西。即使证据被丢弃在那里，现在找回的可能性也很小。流动的河水会将它们冲过城市下方的管道，流向远方。周围的垃圾桶、商店、居民和屋顶也都被检查过，但搜查一无所获。警方将注意力转向了潜在的目击者。一名性工作者告诉他们，她在凌晨1点前曾去过冈恩巷。她没有看到阿尔玛的尸体或任何可疑人员。由于这名女子在当局那里有可靠的声誉，警方确定阿尔玛的尸体是在1点之后被抛弃的。
Residents who lived above Gun Alley didn't recall hearing a thing. Although, even if they had, they wouldn't necessarily have looked outside. Gun Alley was often frequented at night by drunks and drifters, as well as sex workers with their clients. It wasn't unusual to hear an assortment of strange noises emanating from down below. At around 1am, several residents of Little Collins Street reported hearing what sounded like two gunshots being fired in quick succession. They quickly realised it was actually the sound of a car backfiring. They also heard a door being slammed shut. This supported the theory that the killer had transported Elmer's body to Gun Alley under the cover of darkness. But the question remained, where had she been taken first?
住在冈恩巷上方的居民不记得听到过任何声音。不过，即使他们听到了，也不一定会往外看。冈恩巷晚上经常有醉汉和流浪者，以及带着客户的性工作者出没。听到下方传出各种奇怪的声音并不罕见。大约凌晨1点，小科林斯街的几位居民报告说听到了两声类似枪响的声音，接连响起。他们很快意识到那实际上是汽车回火的声音。他们还听到了一扇门被猛地关上的声音。这支持了凶手在夜幕掩护下将阿尔玛的尸体运送到冈恩巷的理论。但问题依然存在，她最初被带到了哪里？
The killer needed privacy and time to not only assault Alma but clean her body too. Investigators therefore believed he must have taken her somewhere familiar where he didn't run the risk of being caught in the act. For that reason, shared housing seemed unlikely. Local hotels and lodgings were checked and ruled out. It was also possible that the killer lived with his family but had time alone while they went away for the holiday period. Yet Alma was manually strangled. This was common in attacks where the killer felt pressured to silence their victim. After killing Alma, common sense dictated that the perpetrator wouldn't have wanted to transport her body very far. The surrounding city streets were never completely deserted, no matter the hour.
凶手需要隐私和时间，不仅要袭击阿尔玛，还要清洗她的尸体。因此，调查人员认为他一定把她带到了某个熟悉的地方，在那里他不会冒被当场抓住的风险。出于这个原因，合租房似乎不太可能。当地的酒店和旅馆都经过了检查并被排除。凶手也有可能与家人住在一起，但在他们去度假期间有独处的时间。然而，阿尔玛是被手动勒死的。这在凶手感到有压力要让受害者噤声的袭击中很常见。杀死阿尔玛后，常识告诉我们，肇事者不会想把她的尸体运送得太远。无论什么时间，周围的城市街道从来都不是完全荒无人烟的。
It was possible that he'd carried Alma's body in a bag or in some other inconspicuous way, yet no one had seen a man lugging anything hefty. The city's alcohol-fuelled nightlife might have allowed him to trek along busy thoroughfares completely unnoticed, while the darkened streets, alleys and doorways would have provided him with plenty of hiding spots. Dumping Elmer's body was no doubt a strategic move to prevent investigators from having a crime scene to examine. Still, they weren't sure what to make of this
他有可能用袋子或其他不显眼的方式携带了阿尔玛的尸体，但没有人看到一个男人拖着什么沉重的东西。城市里酒精驱动的夜生活可能让他能够完全不被察觉地穿过繁忙的大道，而黑暗的街道、小巷和门口则为他提供了大量的藏身之处。抛弃阿尔玛的尸体无疑是一个战略举措，旨在防止调查人员拥有可供检查的犯罪现场。尽管如此，他们还是不确定该如何看待这个……
scenario. If the killer had access to a car, why didn't he leave Alma's body somewhere it wouldn't be found? Alma's body was left at the end of Gun Alley after it turned 90 degrees and was no longer visible from the street. Unless one had travelled down the alley before, there was no way of knowing it featured this distinctive turn or reached a dead end. If the killer lived nearby or frequented the area often, he'd know which spots were populated, which were lit, and possibly, the route and timings of police on the beat. possibly the route and timings of police on the beat. Officers tasked with safeguarding this particular area of Melbourne had a set routine. Between 1 and 2am they headed to the nearby Town Hall police depot for a meal and a drink
场景。如果凶手有车，为什么他不把阿尔玛的尸体留在找不到的地方？阿尔玛的尸体被留在冈恩巷的尽头，那里转了90度，从街上已经看不见了。除非以前走过这条巷子，否则不可能知道它有这个独特的转弯或是一条死胡同。如果凶手住在附近或经常出没于该地区，他就会知道哪些地方有人，哪些地方有灯光，甚至可能知道巡警的路线和时间。甚至可能知道巡警的路线和时间。负责保卫墨尔本这一特定区域的警官有一套固定的程序。在凌晨1点到2点之间，他们会前往附近的市政厅警察局吃点东西、喝点水，
before going back out. The killer's movement seemed incredibly well timed to fit this gap. The officer on the beat that night was required to check every lane and alley on the block. Less than an hour after the sex worker left a gun alley, the officer reached the top of the alley and peered into the darkness. Not noticing anything odd, he continued on his route. Had he performed his duties properly and gone into the alley, he might have come across Alma's body and possibly her killer. Even if
然后再回去。凶手的行动时间似乎把握得非常好，正好卡在这个空档。当晚负责巡逻的警官需要检查街区内的每一条小巷。在性工作者离开冈恩巷不到一小时后，警官到达了巷口，向黑暗中望去。没有发现任何异常，他继续他的巡逻路线。如果他履行了职责并进入了小巷，他可能会发现阿尔玛的尸体，甚至可能发现她的凶手。即使……
the killer had already fled, it was likely he'd still been in the vicinity and there would have been a greater chance of him being caught. With her long golden red hair, freckled face and school uniform, Alma Tursky cut a memorable figure and several witnesses recalled seeing her on the afternoon of her disappearance. After picking up the parcel from her uncle's butcher, Alma was seen walking in the direction of her aunt's flat on Collins Street. Unlike the exclusive and opulent precinct that it is today, in the 1920s the Collins Street area was regarded as a disreputable part of Melbourne. In the words of the Herald newspaper, its atmosphere was squalid and depressing. The streets were lined with decrepit, dated buildings crammed between
凶手已经逃跑，他很可能还在附近，被抓住的可能性也会更大。阿尔玛·特斯基留着一头金红色的长发，长着雀斑，穿着校服，形象令人难忘，几位目击者回忆起在她失踪那天下午见过她。从她叔叔的肉铺取回包裹后，有人看到阿尔玛朝着科林斯街她姑姑公寓的方向走去。与今天的高档和富裕区域不同，在20世纪20年代，科林斯街地区被认为是墨尔本名声不佳的地方。用《先驱报》的话说，那里的气氛“肮脏而压抑”。街道两旁挤满了破旧、过时的建筑，夹在……
cheap and gloomy lodging houses. The Age newspaper described it as an unsavoury quarter of undesirables. A witness saw Alma slowly turn up Little Collins Street, looking up at the buildings as if she was lost. Had she continued up Little Collins Street and taken a left, she would have reached her destination. However, at 2.30 someone else spotted her on Burke Street. This meant she'd taken a right. A mother and daughter incidentally trailed Alma for a short distance until she entered the Eastern Arcade, a two-level building next to the Eastern Market, across the road from Gun Alley. The Arcade served as a thoroughfare from Burke to Little Collins Street. Its long, narrow, enclosed court interior was mostly desolate.
廉价而阴暗的旅馆之间。《时代报》将其描述为“不受欢迎之人的肮脏区域”。一名目击者看到阿尔玛慢慢转入小科林斯街，抬头看着建筑物，好像迷路了一样。如果她继续沿小科林斯街走并向左转，她就能到达目的地。然而，下午2点30分，有人在伯克街（Burke Street）看到了她。这意味着她向右转了。一对母女顺便跟踪了阿尔玛一小段路，直到她进入了东部拱廊（Eastern Arcade），这是一座位于东部市场旁边、冈恩巷对面的一栋两层建筑。拱廊是通往伯克街到小科林斯街的通道。其长、窄、封闭的庭院内部大多荒凉。
Many of the shops within were empty, save for fifty or so businesses between both floors, including a tobacconist, a herbalist, and second-hand dealers. Drab, dark and dusty, the building reeked of mustiness. Neglected grime had crusted over the ornate glass domed roof preventing sunlight from pouring in and cobwebs dangled from all corners and crevices. The Arcade's inhabitants were rough. Most were on the fringe of society and or living in poverty, but there were other unconventional characters like fortune tellers and mediums. As The Age described, and mediums. As The Age described,
里面的许多商店都是空的，两层楼之间只有五十家左右的企业，包括一家烟草店、一家草药店和二手经销商。建筑阴暗、灰暗、尘土飞扬，散发着霉味。被忽视的污垢结在华丽的玻璃圆顶屋顶上，阻挡了阳光射入，蜘蛛网从所有角落和缝隙中垂下。拱廊里的居民很粗鲁。大多数人处于社会边缘或生活在贫困中，但也有其他非传统的角色，如算命师和灵媒。正如《时代报》所描述的，正如《时代报》所描述的，
From the early days of Melbourne, this section of the city has been the haunt of thieves and gamblers and other people of low type, a haven for evil characters. Most of the Arcade's regulars were suspicious of police and reluctant to speak with them. suspicious of police and reluctant to speak with them. There was no known reason for Alma to enter the Eastern Arcade. Alma's grandmother suggested she might have gone in to use the public restroom. Whatever the case, it was unlikely Alma was aware of the arcade's seedy reputation. Towards the little Collins Street exit of the Eastern Arcade was a bar called the Australian Wine Saloon. It too drew in a bad crowd. Anyone was served there, regardless of age. Customers were often spotted around Little Collins Street at all hours in varying states of intoxication, vomiting, urinating and confronting passes by. The
“从墨尔本早期开始，这一区域就是小偷、赌徒和其他低等人的出没地，是邪恶之人的避风港。”大多数拱廊的常客对警察持怀疑态度，不愿与他们交谈。阿尔玛进入东部拱廊没有任何已知原因。阿尔玛的祖母建议她可能是进去使用公共洗手间。无论如何，阿尔玛不太可能知道拱廊的名声不好。在东部拱廊的小科林斯街出口处，有一家名为“澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙”（Australian Wine Saloon）的酒吧。它也吸引了糟糕的人群。无论年龄大小，任何人都会在那里得到服务。顾客经常在小科林斯街各处被发现，处于不同程度的醉酒状态，呕吐、排尿并骚扰路人。这家……
Australian wine saloon was owned and operated by a man named Colin Ross. Shortly before 3 p.m. on Friday December 30, Colin briefly stepped out of his saloon and happened to see Alma Tursky. She paced around as if looking for somebody before exiting the arcade. The next sighting of Alma was as she crossed Little Collins Street just a few hundred meters from where she'd started her journey. It had taken her 90 minutes to walk in a circle around a city block. Even more troubling, when witnesses described Alma's demeanour, they used words like nervous, agitated and even frightened. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. on every dollar you contribute when you subscribe to Robinhood Gold. But get this, now through April 30th Robinhood is even boosting every single dollar you transfer in from other retirement
澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙由一个名叫科林·罗斯（Colin Ross）的男人拥有和经营。12月30日星期五下午3点前不久，科林短暂地走出他的沙龙，碰巧看到了阿尔玛·特斯基。她来回踱步，好像在找人，然后离开了拱廊。下一次看到阿尔玛是她穿过小科林斯街，距离她开始旅程的地方只有几百米。她花了90分钟绕着一个城市街区走了一圈。更令人不安的是，当目击者描述阿尔玛的举止时，他们用了“紧张”、“焦虑”甚至“害怕”这样的词。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。当您订阅Robinhood Gold时，您每贡献一美元……但请注意，从现在到4月30日，Robinhood甚至会为您从其他退休账户转入的每一美元提供3%的匹配。没错，3%的匹配没有上限。得益于他们提供3%匹配的IRA，Robinhood Gold让您的退休金获得最大收益。此优惠有效期至4月30日。请访问robinhood.com/boost开始。订阅费适用。现在是一些法律信息。截至2024年第一季度的声明由Radius Global Market Research验证。投资涉及风险，包括损失。IRA和401k有限制。
accounts with a 3% match. That's right, no cap on the 3% match. Robinhood Gold gets you the most for your retirement thanks to their IRA with a 3% match. This offer is good through April 30. Get started at robinhood.com slash boost. Subscription fees apply. And now for some legal info. Claim as of Q1 2024 validated by Radius Global Market Research. Investing involves risk, including loss. Limitations apply to IRAs and 401ks.
（无内容）
3% match requires Robinhood gold for one year from the date of first 3% match. Must keep Robinhood IRA for five years. The 3% matching on transfers is subject to specific terms and conditions. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Alma's journey would have taken her past some slum dwellings on Little Collins Street. Investigators considered whether an unscrupulous loiterer had lured her away, or maybe she'd been stalked by a predator who pounced at an opportunistic moment.
3%匹配需要Robinhood Gold一年，从首次3%匹配之日起算。必须保留Robinhood IRA五年。转账的3%匹配受特定条款和条件约束。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。阿尔玛的旅程本应经过小科林斯街的一些贫民窟。调查人员考虑是否有一个不择手段的游荡者引诱她离开，或者她是否被一个掠食者跟踪，并在机会主义的时刻扑向了她。
Given Alma's unsettled state, she might have known she was being followed and had been wandering around trying to give her pursuer the slip. Alma was obedient and introverted in nature with a soft way of speaking. If something were amiss, she didn't have the tenacity to confront the problem head on. In the words of her uncle, John, head on. In the words of her uncle, John, though of a bright disposition, Alma was somewhat reserved and did not make friends readily like some girls. She lacked the vivacious manner that encourages a chance acquaintance. By the time Alma's body was discovered, her killer had a sizeable head start. Despite the lack of clues or evidence,
考虑到阿尔玛不安的状态，她可能知道自己被跟踪了，并一直在四处游荡，试图甩掉跟踪者。阿尔玛天性顺从、内向，说话轻声细语。如果有什么不对劲，她没有那种直面问题的韧性。用她叔叔约翰的话说，虽然性格开朗，但阿尔玛有些内向，不像有些女孩那样容易交朋友。她缺乏那种鼓励偶然结识的活泼举止。当阿尔玛的尸体被发现时，她的凶手已经有了相当大的领先优势。尽管缺乏线索或证据，
investigators were certain the mystery would be solved within days. The Victorian government offered a 250 pound reward for information that led to a conviction, an amount that was deemed woefully inadequate by the local populace. Given the urgency of this situation, they expected a far higher and more tempting offer. If the investigation took too long, the killer could flee the state, or worse, strike again. But by Tuesday January 3, 1922, four days after Alma's body was discovered, there still hadn't been any arrests. Alma Tursky was laid to rest that day. Her small coffin was adorned with white flowers, with six of her friends acting as pallbearers. Alma's grieving family travelled with her body in the hearse that took her to her final resting place, a plot alongside her recently deceased grandfather
调查人员确信这个谜团会在几天内解开。维多利亚州政府悬赏250英镑征集导致定罪的信息，这个金额被当地民众认为极其不足。考虑到这种情况的紧迫性，他们期待一个更高、更诱人的报价。如果调查时间太长，凶手可能会逃离该州，或者更糟的是，再次作案。但到了1922年1月3日星期二，即阿尔玛尸体被发现四天后，仍然没有任何逮捕行动。阿尔玛·特斯基那天被安葬。她的小棺材上装饰着白花，由她的六个朋友担任护柩者。阿尔玛悲痛欲绝的家人随灵车护送她的尸体前往她最后的安息地，那是她最近去世的祖父旁边的一块墓地，
at Brighton Cemetery. After Alma's funeral, her loved ones went to Gunn Alley for a moment of private reflection. They were confronted by a large crowd of strangers gawking at the crime scene. Gunn Alley had been chaotic since the discovery of Alma's body. A non-stop influx of locals, out of towners, police and news reporters flooded the small area at all hours. Within the first week of January 1922, thousands of people pushed their way through the tight space to observe the area, lay flowers, condemn the perpetrator, and swap theories. A line of people nearly 100 metres long stretched from the alley's entrance, with inconvenienced business owners threatening to hose the onlookers if they didn't disperse. Similar crowds also descended on the eastern arcade, storming into shops and lodgings shouting
位于布莱顿公墓（Brighton Cemetery）。阿尔玛的葬礼结束后，她的亲人们前往冈恩巷进行片刻的私人反思。他们面对的是一大群盯着犯罪现场看的陌生人。自发现阿尔玛的尸体以来，冈恩巷一直处于混乱状态。当地人、外地人、警察和新闻记者不分昼夜地涌入这个小区域。在1922年1月的第一个星期内，成千上万的人挤过狭窄的空间，观察该区域、献花、谴责肇事者并交换理论。一条近100米长的队伍从巷口延伸出来，不便的店主威胁说，如果围观者不散开，就用水管冲他们。类似的人群也涌向东部拱廊，冲进商店和旅馆大喊……
– let us at them! Pull the place down! Alma Turski's murder was the first crime in Melbourne to create such hysteria. The press covered the story exhaustively, releasing detailed updates about the investigation every morning and afternoon that included evidence uncovered and witness accounts. The people of Australia were left reeling. How did a killer strike in broad daylight on the bustling streets of Melbourne's theatre
“让我们进去！把这地方拆了！”阿尔玛·特斯基的谋杀案是墨尔本第一起造成如此歇斯底里的犯罪。媒体对这个故事进行了详尽的报道，每天早上和下午发布关于调查的详细更新，包括发现的证据和目击者陈述。澳大利亚人民感到震惊。一个凶手怎么能在墨尔本剧院区繁忙的街道上光天化日之下行凶？
district? Mothers used Alma's death as a warning to their own children, even though no one fully knew what she'd experienced or by whom. The one thing people did know was that her killer was a cold-blooded, careful predator. As fear gripped the city, members of Melbourne's criminal underworld offered their help by sending the message to the police. You tell us who you want and we'll get him for you." An article in the Age newspaper asserted, "...the circumstances of the case are of such a tragic and revolting character that the whole
母亲们用阿尔玛的死作为对她们自己孩子的警告，尽管没有人完全知道她经历了什么，或者被谁所害。人们唯一知道的是，她的凶手是一个冷血、谨慎的掠食者。随着恐惧笼罩这座城市，墨尔本犯罪地下世界的成员通过向警方传达信息来提供帮助：“你们告诉我们你们想要谁，我们会为你们抓住他。”《时代报》的一篇文章断言：“……案件的情况具有如此悲惨和令人反感的性质，以至于整个……
community should leave no stone unturned to discover the criminal." The issue for police wasn't that they weren't getting enough tips, it's that they were getting too many. Melbourne citizens reported all sorts of suspicious behaviour, including a man who changed his outfit three times in one day. Police were spoken to about everything, from worrisome dreams to clairvoyant visions. The constant pile-on ran the risk of key information being overlooked. Even though the crime scene had been thoroughly examined and cleared by authorities, amateur sleuths muddied the waters by inundating Gunnally and handing over anything they came across, from buttons to a piece of ribbon.
社区应该不遗余力地发现罪犯。”警方的问题不是他们没有得到足够的线索，而是他们得到的太多了。墨尔本市民报告了各种可疑行为，包括一个一天换了三次衣服的男人。从令人担忧的梦境到千里眼般的幻觉，警方被告知了一切。不断的堆积有导致关键信息被忽视的风险。尽管犯罪现场已经过当局的彻底检查和清理，但业余侦探通过涌入冈恩巷并交出他们遇到的任何东西（从纽扣到一段丝带）而搅浑了水。
One man even handed over a parcel of sausages he found behind a drainpipe, thinking it could have been the meat Almaturski had collected from the butcher prior to her murder. In actuality, all of these items had been strewn there by hoaxsters wanting to stir up some drama. Detectives also began receiving anonymous death threats warning them to drop the inquiry. These too were suspected to be from pranksters. Despite the chaos, the police encouraged the community to keep information pouring in. On Thursday January 5, someone who lived near Little Collins Street called in claiming they had important information relating to the case. Several detectives piled into a police car and
甚至有一个人交出了一包他在排水管后面发现的香肠，认为这可能是阿尔玛·特斯基在谋杀前从肉铺取走的肉。实际上，所有这些物品都是想制造一些戏剧性的恶作剧者扔在那里的。侦探们也开始收到匿名的死亡威胁，警告他们放弃调查。这些也被怀疑是恶作剧者所为。尽管混乱不堪，警方还是鼓励社区继续提供信息。1月5日星期四，一位住在小科林斯街附近的人打来电话，声称他们有与案件相关的重要信息。几名侦探挤进一辆警车，
sped towards the destination. As they approached the corner of Lonsdale and Exhibition Streets, a man staggered in front of their car. The driver swerved to avoid them, causing the vehicle's front wheels to lock and skid. The car overturned, throwing two officers from their seats and leaving a third pinned underneath. The officers only sustained broken bones and relatively minor injuries, but the entire fiasco was reported by the press, who had been casting Victoria Police in a mostly negative light from the outset of the Tursky investigation. The detectives involved in the car accident were described as utterly incompetent and on a wild goose chase. The police car involved in the crash was an old, obsolete vehicle that had
加速驶向目的地。当他们接近朗斯代尔街（Lonsdale Street）和展览街（Exhibition Street）的拐角处时，一个男人摇摇晃晃地走到他们的车前。司机猛打方向盘以避开他，导致车辆前轮锁死并打滑。汽车翻倒，将两名警官从座位上甩出，第三名警官被压在下面。警官们只受了骨折和相对轻微的伤，但整个惨败被媒体报道，他们从特斯基调查一开始就一直以负面眼光看待维多利亚州警方。参与车祸的侦探被描述为“极其无能”和“在进行徒劳的追逐”。涉及车祸的警车是一辆陈旧、过时的车辆，
earned the nickname among officers as the suicide car due to its poor and dangerous state. Its continued usage highlighted the problems Victoria Police faced in the wake of Walmaturski's murder. For starters, investigators hadn't been supplied with electric torches. Instead, they relied on matches to search the dark alleyways and other locations. The same went for the officer who had been tasked with checking Gun Alley on the night of the crime. If he'd had better resources, some questioned how things could have worked out differently. Then there was the matter of the police photographer who shared his services across all government departments. As researcher Kevin Morgan explained in his book Gun Alley, it was not uncommon for police to be told on making
由于其糟糕和危险的状态，在警官中赢得了“自杀车”的绰号。它的持续使用凸显了维多利亚州警方在阿尔玛·特斯基谋杀案后所面临的问题。首先，调查人员没有配备电筒。相反，他们依靠火柴来搜寻黑暗的小巷和其他地方。负责在案发当晚检查冈恩巷的警官也是如此。如果他有更好的资源，有些人质疑事情会如何不同。然后是摄影师的问题，他为所有政府部门提供服务。正如研究员凯文·摩根（Kevin Morgan）在他的书《冈恩巷》（Gun Alley）中所解释的那样，警察在提出……
application for the photographer's services that he had been dispatched to country Victoria to photograph new fruit picking techniques or new harvesting equipment, and that he would not be back in Melbourne for several days. As a result, Gunn Alley wasn't photographed for the purpose of the homicide investigation until mid-January 1922, weeks after Alma Tershki was killed. This meant no photographs had been taken of her body in situ or in the mortuary. At the time, it was the sole duty of detectives to examine and interpret a crime scene. Even though forensic sciences were not entirely new, few in Victoria were trained in its most recent developments. Not only did the police lack the expertise they needed, they also lacked manpower. When Elmer's body was first discovered, only three officers were dispatched to Gun Alley.
申请摄影师服务时，被告知他已被派往维多利亚州乡村去拍摄新的水果采摘技术或新的收割设备，并且几天内不会回到墨尔本，这种情况并不罕见。因此，冈恩巷直到1922年1月中旬，即阿尔玛·特斯基被杀几周后，才为了凶杀案调查而进行拍摄。这意味着没有拍摄到她尸体在现场或停尸房的照片。当时，检查和解释犯罪现场是侦探的唯一职责。尽管法医学并非完全是新的，但维多利亚州很少有人受过其最新发展的培训。警方不仅缺乏他们需要的专业知识，还缺乏人力。当阿尔玛的尸体首次被发现时，只有三名警官被派往冈恩巷。
This was barely enough to maintain the integrity of the crime scene, let alone close off the surrounding area to search for the killer. Curious onlookers and news reporters had trudged their way through the alley before it could be cordoned off and guarded. With the limited resources they had, it took the police days to properly examine the crime scene, not to mention the greater area. As Victoria Police faced growing criticism, the government upped the reward in Elmer's case to £1,000. This was one of the biggest rewards
这几乎不足以维持犯罪现场的完整性，更不用说封锁周围区域以搜寻凶手了。好奇的围观者和新闻记者在小巷被封锁和守卫之前就已经蹒跚而行。由于资源有限，警方花了几天时间才正确检查了犯罪现场，更不用说更大的区域了。随着维多利亚州警方面临越来越多的批评，政府将阿尔玛案件的悬赏金提高到1000英镑。这是最大的悬赏金之一。
ever offered in Australian history, enough to buy several houses and live a comfortable life. The increase was well received by the community. It served as both a face-saving strategy for the government and a timely distraction of the underlying issues that plagued the police. Meanwhile, the relationship between the police and the press remained rocky. While both were set on identifying Alma's killer and worked in tandem at times, the press' criticism hurt relations. Within days of Alma's murder, they'd portrayed the police as having failed ingloriously for not making any arrests. They started demanding a royal commission into the police's incompetence, and the public had little confidence in law enforcement as a result.
是澳大利亚历史上提供的最高悬赏，足以买下几栋房子并过上舒适的生活。这一增长受到了社区的欢迎。这既是政府挽回面子的策略，也是对困扰警察的潜在问题的及时转移。与此同时，警方与媒体之间的关系依然紧张。虽然双方都致力于查明阿尔玛的凶手，有时也协同工作，但媒体的批评损害了双方的关系。在阿尔玛遇害后的几天里，他们将警方描绘成因未能逮捕任何人而丢脸地失败了。他们开始要求对警方的无能进行皇家调查，结果公众对执法部门几乎失去了信心。
The pressure on detectives to solve the case quickly was immense. One detective told the press, any day now we expect to get our man. The editor of the Argus newspaper doubted this, writing, as each day passes, the grievous disappointment of the public at the failure of the police to track down the murderer of Alma Turski grows more profound. The detective and police forces of Melbourne are on trial, and no matter how exacting they may find the ordeal, they must realise that the public will not tolerate failure on their part. Working on the theory that Alma's killer had to be local
侦探们迅速破案的压力巨大。一位侦探告诉媒体，我们预计很快就能抓到凶手。《阿格斯报》的编辑对此表示怀疑，他写道，随着每一天的过去，公众对警方未能追踪到阿尔玛·特斯基谋杀案凶手的深切失望感愈发强烈。墨尔本的侦探和警察部队正处于审判之中，无论他们觉得这种磨难多么严苛，他们都必须意识到，公众不会容忍他们的失败。基于阿尔玛的凶手一定是当地人的理论
to the area surrounding Gunn Alley, police questioned various frequenters of the Eastern Arcade. Among them was the proprietor of the Australian wine saloon, 28-year-old Colin Ross, who had reported seeing Alma walk past his saloon at around 2.30pm. The mother and daughter who saw Alma enter the Eastern Arcade verified Colin's account. They not only saw Alma but also remember seeing Colin Ross as he stepped outside of his establishment to observe the Arcade. When they glanced back, both Elmer and Colin were gone. The Australian wine saloon took up two shop floors of the arcade's ground level. Inside the entrance, an arched doorway on the right led to the neighbouring shop floor where the saloon's
在冈恩巷周边地区，警方询问了东拱廊的几位常客。其中包括澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙的店主，28岁的科林·罗斯，他曾报告说看到阿尔玛在下午2点30分左右走过他的沙龙。看到阿尔玛进入东拱廊的那对母女证实了科林的说法。她们不仅看到了阿尔玛，还记得看到科林·罗斯走出他的店面观察拱廊。当她们回头看时，埃尔默和科林都不见了。澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙占据了拱廊底层的两个店面。入口内，右侧的一个拱形门通向隔壁的店面，那里是沙龙的
parlour was located. To the left sat the bar. Behind the bar was a small, curtained-off room that contained a couch with two blankets on it, as well as the opening to the cellar. According to the staff, this was a private room used only by Colin Ross. If the curtain was closed, it meant no one was allowed to enter. Colin had first reported his sighting of Alma to two detectives who visited his saloon the day after the 12-year-old's body was discovered. When one detective asked him, how much do you know Ross, he replied, I don't know anything at all. He replied, "'I don't know anything at all.'"
客厅所在的位置。左侧是吧台。吧台后面是一个用帘子隔开的小房间，里面有一张铺着两条毯子的沙发，还有一个通往地窖的入口。据员工说，这是科林·罗斯专用的私人房间。如果帘子拉上，就意味着任何人不得进入。科林在12岁女孩的尸体被发现后的第二天，首次向两名访问他沙龙的侦探报告了他看到阿尔玛的情况。当一名侦探问他，罗斯，你知道多少时，他回答说，我什么都不知道。他回答说：“‘我什么都不知道。’”
Over the days that followed, Colin and other arcade regulars were questioned several times. Elaborating on his movements from Friday December 30, Colin said that he'd arrived at his saloon at around 2pm. The bar was quiet, so he wandered out the front to take in the happenings around the Eastern Arcade. That's when he glimpsed Alma Tursky walk past. Colin then went back into his saloon and remained there until closing time at 6pm. At 6.10 he travelled to the suburb of Footscray where he lived with his mother and brothers. He ate dinner before heading back to the city.
在随后的几天里，科林和其他拱廊常客被多次询问。科林详细说明了他在12月30日星期五的行踪，他说他大约在下午2点到达他的沙龙。酒吧很安静，所以他走到前面去看看东拱廊周围发生的事情。就在那时，他瞥见阿尔玛·特斯基走了过去。科林随后回到他的沙龙，一直待到下午6点关门。6点10分，他前往富茨克雷郊区，他和母亲及兄弟住在一起。他吃过晚饭后又回到了城里。
Colin had planned to meet his friend Gladys at the Eastern Arcade at 9pm. Arriving early, he wandered around Little Colin Street aimlessly for 15 minutes before catching up with Gladys and taking her to the Australian wine saloon. Given it was after hours, they were the only two inside. They stayed there until 10.45, at which point Colin locked the place up and walked to Gladys the roughly 20 minute journey to her flat on King Street. He then went to Spencer Street Station and took a train home, where he stayed for the rest of the night. Gladys confirmed Colin's version of events, but she said they left the saloon at 10.20pm, 25 minutes earlier than what Colin had stated. According to Gladys, the pair spoke outside of
科林计划晚上9点在东拱廊见他的朋友格拉迪斯。他提前到达，在小科林街漫无目的地徘徊了15分钟，然后赶上格拉迪斯，带她去了澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙。因为已经过了营业时间，他们是里面仅有的两个人。他们一直待到10点45分，这时科林锁上门，陪格拉迪斯走了大约20分钟的路程回到她在国王街的公寓。然后他去了斯宾塞街车站，乘火车回家，并在那里度过了剩下的夜晚。格拉迪斯证实了科林的说法，但她说他们在晚上10点20分离开了沙龙，比科林所说的早了25分钟。据格拉迪斯说，两人在
her flat for a while before parting ways at 11.15. Cladis watched Colin walk off and was under the impression that he was heading home. Although Colin Ross was simply being questioned in relation to the Almatyerski case, rumours quickly spread that police had placed him under arrest for her murder. A 3,000 strong crowd gathered at the entrance of the Eastern Arcade shouting for officers to bring him out. The building was locked down as officers on horseback arrived to disperse the angry crowd. For the general public who absorbed all of their information about the case from the press, Colin Ross was exactly the type of man who would kill Alma Tursky. There was no doubt about that. A little under two years earlier, in March 1920, police received a call from Colin's
她的公寓外聊了一会儿，然后分道扬镳。克拉迪斯看着科林走开，以为他要回家。尽管科林·罗斯只是因阿尔玛·特斯基案受到询问，但很快就有传言称警方已因谋杀罪将他逮捕。3000多名群众聚集在东拱廊入口处，大喊着让警察把他带出来。大楼被封锁，骑警赶到驱散愤怒的人群。对于那些从媒体获取案件所有信息的公众来说，科林·罗斯正是那种会杀害阿尔玛·特斯基的人。这一点毫无疑问。大约两年前，即1920年3月，警方接到了科林
then-girlfriend, Lily. She claimed that Colin had threatened her with a revolver after she rejected his marriage proposal, saying that he'd have her dead or alive. Terrified, Lily had accepted his proposal just to placate him, but then called the police as soon as he left. Colin was charged with using threatening words towards a young woman and carrying firearms without permission. He avoided a 14 day stint in jail by agreeing to a 12 month good behaviour bond with a £5 fine. More recently, a patron of the Australian wine saloon was robbed of his cash and shot in the shoulder. Several people were suspected of being involved in the crime, including Colin Ross, and he was subsequently charged with armed robbery.
当时的女友莉莉的电话。她声称科林在拒绝了他的求婚后用左轮手枪威胁她，说他要让她死或活。惊恐万分的莉莉为了安抚他接受了他的求婚，但他在离开后立即报了警。科林被控对一名年轻女性使用威胁性语言并未经许可携带枪支。他通过同意签署一份12个月的良好行为保证书并缴纳5英镑罚款，避免了14天的牢狱之灾。最近，一名澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙的顾客被抢走了现金并被击中肩膀。几个人被怀疑参与了这起犯罪，包括科林·罗斯，他随后被控武装抢劫。
Yet, the victim had been heavily intoxicated and couldn't recall who was responsible for his injuries. Investigators were left with conflicting accounts from the disreputable accused, who lobbed blame at each other, and Colin was ultimately acquitted. A criminal with a penchant for violent acts, Colin Ross fit the bill of a killer. He had a burly, strong figure and could have easily intimidated and overpowered little Alma Tursky. He matched the police's suspect profile, being a local business owner familiar with the area. Yet, they hadn't uncovered anything to justify his arrest for Alma's murder. Detectives quizzed Colin about his relationship with women.
然而，受害者当时醉得很厉害，记不清是谁造成了他的伤害。调查人员只能从这些名声不佳的被告那里得到相互矛盾的陈述，他们互相指责，科林最终被判无罪。作为一个有暴力倾向的罪犯，科林·罗斯符合杀手的特征。他身材魁梧强壮，很容易恐吓并制服瘦小的阿尔玛·特斯基。他符合警方的嫌疑人画像，是一名熟悉该地区的当地企业主。然而，他们没有发现任何足以证明他因谋杀阿尔玛而被捕的证据。侦探们盘问了科林关于他与女性的关系。
Through their inquiries, they'd been told that Colin was known to boast about his sexual prowess, claiming that he was, quote, the largest sexually made man. He allegedly said that if his sexual partners didn't do what he wanted them to, he would, quote, strangle the bastards. Though police never revealed their sources for this information, it was no secret that they'd questioned many sex workers in the aftermath of Elmuterski's murder, and Colin was known to engage their services. When confronted with these statements, Colin asserted it was all lies. He seemed perplexed that anyone would say these things about him, so much so that he arrived at police headquarters to find out who had. Detectives refused to tell Colin their sources
通过调查，他们被告知科林以吹嘘自己的性能力而闻名，声称自己是，引用，“最强壮的性爱男人”。据称他说，如果他的性伴侣不按他的意愿行事，他就会，引用，“勒死这些混蛋”。虽然警方从未透露这些信息的来源，但众所周知，他们在阿尔玛·特斯基谋杀案发生后询问了许多性工作者，而科林以使用她们的服务而闻名。当面对这些陈述时，科林断言这全是谎言。他似乎对有人会这样说他感到困惑，以至于他来到警察总部想找出是谁说的。侦探们拒绝告诉科林他们的消息来源
and asked why he was so anxious to know. Colin replied that he didn't believe anyone said those things about him. If they had, Colin said that he'd, quote, warm them up. Sensing an opportunity, detectives tried to provoke Colin in the hopes he might react by doing something that implicated him in Alma Turski's murder. Replying to Colin's threat, one detective said, "'Very good. Try it.'" But Colin kept his cool and continued to fully cooperate with investigators. He even suggested they look into two men who occupied an upstairs room on the opposite side of the arcade to his saloon. His tip only raised detective's suspicion as they felt Colin was trying to divert attention from
并问他为什么这么急于知道。科林回答说他不相信有人会那样说他。如果他们说了，科林说他会，引用，“给他们点颜色看看”。侦探们察觉到机会，试图挑衅科林，希望他能做出一些让他卷入阿尔玛·特斯基谋杀案的行为。回应科林的威胁，一名侦探说：“‘很好。试试看。’”但科林保持冷静，并继续全力配合调查人员。他甚至建议他们调查两名占据拱廊对面楼上房间的男子。他的建议反而引起了侦探的怀疑，因为他们觉得科林是在试图转移注意力
himself. Still, he willingly provided follow-up statements whenever asked, and his story never changed. It was always presented with an air of confidence, as though he had nothing to hide. On the day that Almaterski's body was discovered, the Australian Wine Saloon's liquor licence happened to expire, marking its final day of trade. Colin had attempted to renew it, but Victoria Police ensured the application was rejected due to Colin's criminal behaviour and the many complaints they'd received from neighbouring businesses regarding the saloon's rowdy patrons. Colin had no choice but to close the establishment down. By the time detectives got around to examining the saloon on Tuesday January 3, four days had passed since Alma's body was found. By then, the entire building had already been completely emptied and gutted.
离开自己。尽管如此，他还是在被要求时自愿提供了后续陈述，他的故事从未改变。它总是以一种自信的态度呈现，仿佛他没有什么可隐瞒的。在阿尔玛·特斯基的尸体被发现的那天，澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙的酒牌恰好到期，标志着它最后一天营业。科林曾试图续期，但维多利亚州警方确保申请被拒绝，原因是科林的犯罪行为以及他们从邻近企业收到的关于沙龙吵闹顾客的许多投诉。科林别无选择，只能关闭该场所。当侦探们在1月3日星期二检查沙龙时，距离阿尔玛的尸体被发现已经过去了四天。到那时，整栋建筑已经被完全清空并拆除。
Two weeks later, on Thursday January 12, detectives visited Colin Ross at home. They noticed a pair of blankets folded up under a pillow on his couch, one brownish-red in colour, the other a grey-blue. Colin said the blankets had previously been in his saloon, slung over a couch in the curtained-off room behind the bar. Looking at the brown blanket, one of the detectives noticed a long red hair stuck to it. The blankets were confiscated for further analysis. All up, a total of 22 red hairs were recovered on the brown blanket. The blue blanket also contained five red hairs,
两周后，即1月12日星期四，侦探们拜访了家中的科林·罗斯。他们注意到沙发上的枕头下叠着两条毯子，一条是棕红色的，另一条是灰蓝色的。科林说这些毯子以前在他的沙龙里，挂在吧台后面用帘子隔开的房间里的沙发上。看着那条棕色的毯子，其中一名侦探注意到上面粘着一根长红发。毯子被没收以进行进一步分析。总共在棕色毯子上发现了22根红发。蓝色毯子上也包含五根红发，
as well as two semen stains. Prior to Alma Turski's burial, a lock of her hair had been placed inside an envelope to aid with future investigations. An analyst compared the hairs found on the blankets to Elmer's. They concluded that all of the hairs had derived from the scalp of the same person. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. At the police station, Colin Ross maintained that on Friday December 30 he'd walked his friend Gladys back to her flat before catching the train home.
以及两处精液污渍。在阿尔玛·特斯基下葬前，她的一缕头发被放入信封中，以协助未来的调查。分析师将毯子上发现的头发与埃尔默的进行了比较。他们得出结论，所有的头发都来自同一个人的头皮。案件档案很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。在警察局，科林·罗斯坚持说，12月30日星期五，他送朋友格拉迪斯回到她的公寓，然后乘火车回家。
He added that he got home at around midnight and went straight to bed. Once again, detectives switched their line of questioning to Colin's personal life. They said a source had told them that Colin had a habit of exposing himself when drunk. Colin denied this, saying, that is a lie and I do not believe any person told you that." The interviewing detective Fred Pigott responded, "'Do you think I am lying?' Colin moulded over before replying, "'I won't say that.'" His response intrigued detectives as it wasn't an outright denial.
他补充说，他大约在午夜回到家，直接上床睡觉。侦探们再次将询问方向转向科林的个人生活。他们说有消息来源告诉他们，科林有喝醉后暴露自己的习惯。科林否认了这一点，说：“那是谎言，我不相信任何人会告诉你这些。”负责采访的侦探弗雷德·皮戈特回应道：“‘你认为我在撒谎吗？’”科林沉思了一会儿，然后回答说：“‘我不会那样说。’”他的回答引起了侦探们的兴趣，因为它不是直接的否认。
In a way, his coy answer seems like an admission. For Detective Pigott, this was a huge step in the right direction. What Colin didn't know was that someone had already come forward implicating him in Alma's murder. Olive Maddix was a sex worker by trade and a regular visitor at the Australian Wine Saloon. She considered Colin Ross a friend, even though he'd unsuccessfully propositioned her for sex on multiple occasions. Olive had told police that she'd been at Colin's saloon at 5pm on Friday, December 30. After ordering a drink, she stood in the archway to the parlour to see if she recognised anyone inside. Sitting alone in a corner was a young woman wearing a dress with red hair flowing down from under her hat. She had a glass in front of her,
在某种程度上，他闪烁其词的回答看起来像是一种承认。对于皮戈特侦探来说，这是朝着正确方向迈出的一大步。科林不知道的是，已经有人站出来指控他谋杀阿尔玛。奥利夫·马迪克斯是一名职业性工作者，也是澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙的常客。她认为科林·罗斯是朋友，尽管他曾多次向她求欢未果。奥利夫告诉警方，她在12月30日星期五下午5点在科林的沙龙。点了一杯酒后，她站在客厅的拱门处，看看是否认出里面的人。角落里独自坐着一个年轻女子，穿着一件裙子，红色的头发从帽子下流淌下来。她面前有一杯酒，
but Olive wasn't sure what it contained. According to Olive, she approached Colin Ross at the bar and told him there was a girl in the parlour who appeared too young to be drinking there. Colin smiled and responded sarcastically, Oh well, if she wants it, she can have it. Olive left the saloon shortly after, noting that the girl was still there. When she returned almost an hour later, it was five minutes till closing time and neither the girl nor Colin Ross were anywhere to be seen. Olive claimed to have crossed paths with Colin Ross again six days later on Thursday January 5, when he asked for her thoughts on Alma Turski's murder.
但奥利夫不确定里面装的是什么。据奥利夫说，她走到吧台前告诉科林·罗斯，客厅里有个女孩看起来太小，不应该在那里喝酒。科林微笑着讽刺地回答说，哦，好吧，如果她想要，她就可以喝。奥利夫不久后离开了沙龙，注意到那个女孩还在那里。当她近一个小时后回来时，距离关门还有五分钟，女孩和科林·罗斯都不见了。奥利夫声称六天后的1月5日星期四再次与科林·罗斯相遇，当时他询问她对阿尔玛·特斯基谋杀案的看法。
Olive didn't know much about it, but Colin had plenty to say. He started lambasting Alma, claiming the papers were making her out to be goody-goody when she was in fact, quote, a cheeky little devil. He said that the little girl was at an age where she wanted a man. Colin's comments disturbed Olif, but she couldn't say with certainty that the girl she'd seen in his saloon had been Alma Turski. While they bore a resemblance and the girl had been wearing clothes that fit the description of Alma's school uniform, the parlour had been poorly lit so she couldn't be entirely sure. But Olive Maddox's account was just one piece of a damning puzzle forming against Colin. Detectives had learnt that Olive wasn't the only one who claimed to have seen a girl matching
奥利夫对此了解不多，但科林有很多话要说。他开始抨击阿尔玛，声称报纸把她描绘成一个乖乖女，而实际上她是一个，引用，“厚颜无耻的小恶魔”。他说那个小女孩正处于想要男人的年纪。科林的评论让奥利夫感到不安，但她不能肯定地说她在他的沙龙里看到的女孩就是阿尔玛·特斯基。虽然她们长得很像，而且那个女孩穿的衣服符合阿尔玛校服的描述，但客厅光线昏暗，所以她不能完全确定。但奥利夫·马迪克斯的陈述只是针对科林的令人震惊的拼图中的一小块。侦探们得知，奥利夫并不是唯一一个声称看到一个女孩符合
Alma Tursky's description at the Australian wine saloon. Ivy Matthews was a bartender and former employee of Colin Ross. She told the police that on December 30 she'd dropped into the saloon at around 3pm. As she approached the bar, Colin emerged from his private room, leaving the curtain open long enough for Ivy to catch a glimpse of a young, redheaded girl sitting on a chair inside. Ivy wasn't sure what to make of the situation. She wondered whether the girl's mother was also in the room, just out of sight. Ivy watched Colin pour a glass of wine before returning back behind the curtain. She left the saloon shortly after, but her observations continued to bother her.
阿尔玛·特斯基描述的人出现在澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙。艾薇·马修斯是一名酒保，也是科林·罗斯的前雇员。她告诉警方，12月30日下午3点左右，她顺道去了沙龙。当她走近吧台时，科林从他的私人房间出来，帘子打开的时间足够让艾薇瞥见一个年轻的红发女孩坐在里面的椅子上。艾薇不知道该怎么看待这种情况。她想知道女孩的母亲是否也在房间里，只是没看见。艾薇看着科林倒了一杯酒，然后退回到帘子后面。她不久后离开了沙龙，但她的观察一直困扰着她。
Ivy already thought Colin Ross was a pervert. She claimed to have previously seen him follow and accost children around the arcade and had warned him to leave them alone. and accost children around the arcade and had warned him to leave them alone. According to Ivy, when she learned of Alma Tursky's murder on December 31, she immediately confronted Colin at work about the girl she'd seen in his back room. Colin swiftly ushered Ivy outside and onto Little Colin Street so they could talk privately. He had admitted that he'd been standing outside his saloon when Elmer approached and asked him for a drink. He said that he led her inside and into the back room. Colin assured Ivy that he didn't do anything to
艾薇一直认为科林·罗斯是个变态。她声称曾见过他在拱廊周围跟踪和骚扰儿童，并警告他离他们远点。据艾薇说，当她在12月31日得知阿尔玛·特斯基被谋杀时，她立即在工作场所就她在后屋看到的女孩与科林对质。科林迅速将艾薇带到外面，来到小科林街，以便他们私下交谈。他承认当埃尔默走近并向他要酒喝时，他正站在沙龙外面。他说他把她带进里面，带进了后屋。科林向艾薇保证他没有对
Elmer but implied that she'd been with men before. He said he'd intended to move her on when his bar closed, but she wouldn't leave. But Colin soon changed his tune. He allegedly broke down, telling Ivy that he suffered from a disease where being in the presence of a child caused him to lose his head. He confessed that he'd quote, ravished Alma and that without meaning to, she was dead before he knew it. Afterwards, he wrapped Alma's body in the blankets from the back room and went home. He drove back to the saloon in the early hours of the morning and used his car to move Alma's body to Gun Alley. As Colin told Ivy this, he was visibly distraught. According to Ivy, he said that after killing Alma, he'd felt like getting a knife and finishing himself. Interviewing detectives presented Colin Ross with the allegations from Olive Maddix and Ivy Matthews.
埃尔默做什么，但暗示她以前和男人在一起过。他说他打算在酒吧关门时让她离开，但她不肯走。但科林很快改变了口风。据称他崩溃了，告诉艾薇他患有一种疾病，在孩子面前会导致他失去理智。他承认他，引用，“蹂躏了阿尔玛”，并且在无意中，在他意识到之前她就已经死了。之后，他用后屋的毯子包裹了阿尔玛的尸体，然后回家了。他在凌晨开车回到沙龙，并用他的车把阿尔玛的尸体运到了冈恩巷。当科林告诉艾薇这些时，他明显心烦意乱。据艾薇说，他说在杀死阿尔玛后，他曾想拿一把刀结束自己的生命。负责采访的侦探向科林·罗斯提出了奥利夫·马迪克斯和艾薇·马修斯的指控。
He called them deliberate lies, saying, You can get nothing on me. Colin Ross was nevertheless charged with the murder of Alma Tursky. As he was led away for processing, his relaxed attitude faltered and he began yelling about a frame up. His mother and brothers accepted his assertions of innocence and contacted a lawyer. Colin was scheduled to appear in court the next day. By then, news of his arrest had made headlines, making him the most hated man in Australia. A large angry crowd amassed at the city court calling for Colin's head as the police tried in vain to disperse them. Colin was transported into the building via a direct passage from the police station cells to bypass the raging mob. Colin appeared optimistic
他称这些是蓄意的谎言，说，你从我这里什么也得不到。尽管如此，科林·罗斯还是被控谋杀阿尔玛·特斯基。当他被带走处理时，他放松的态度动摇了，他开始大喊大叫关于陷害的事。他的母亲和兄弟接受了他无罪的断言，并联系了一名律师。科林定于第二天出庭。到那时，他被捕的消息已成为头条新闻，使他成为澳大利亚最受憎恨的人。一大群愤怒的群众聚集在市法院，要求科林的头，警察试图驱散他们，但无济于事。科林通过从警察局牢房到法院的直接通道被送入大楼，以绕过愤怒的暴民。科林显得很乐观
about his situation, though wept after briefly speaking with his mother. His nerves kicked in once he was in front of the judges. Detective Fred Pigott detailed the case against the accused. He spoke of Colin's sighting of Alma at the Eastern Arcade, but added nothing further, simply saying, There is other evidence which at this stage the police do not wish to disclose. A coronial inquest into Alma Tursky's death was scheduled to determine if Colin Ross would stand trial for her murder. He objected to being remanded in custody until then, telling the court that he'd prefer to be out so witnesses could come to him and prove his whereabouts on the night Alma was killed. The remark was ill
关于他的处境，但在与母亲简短交谈后哭了。一旦站在法官面前，他的神经就开始紧张起来。弗雷德·皮戈特侦探详细说明了针对被告的案件。他谈到了科林在东拱廊看到阿尔玛的情况，但没有补充更多内容，只是说，还有其他证据，现阶段警方不愿披露。对阿尔玛·特斯基死亡的验尸官调查定于确定科林·罗斯是否会因谋杀她而受审。他反对在此之前被还押候审，告诉法庭他宁愿出来，这样证人可以来找他，证明他在阿尔玛被杀之夜的行踪。这一言论被认为
considered, as it only further cemented the judge's belief that Colin needed to be remanded. Colin pleaded, but there is no reason why I should be here. With that, his mother Edie abruptly stood up in the public gallery and announced, I can prove where he was. One of Edie's sons quietened her and pulled her back down to her seat. Colin Ross was remanded until the Coronial Inquest. As he left the dock in an apparent state of shock, he remarked sarcastically, this is a great country, there's no doubt about it. While Colin was on remand, a fellow prisoner named Sydney Harding came forward to the police
考虑不周，因为它进一步巩固了法官认为科林需要被还押的信念。科林恳求道，但我没有理由待在这里。话音刚落，他的母亲伊迪突然在公众席上站起来宣布，我可以证明他在哪里。伊迪的一个儿子让她安静下来，把她拉回座位上。科林·罗斯被还押直到验尸官调查。当他离开被告席时，处于明显的震惊状态，他讽刺地评论道，这是一个伟大的国家，毫无疑问。当科林被还押时，一名叫悉尼·哈丁的狱友向警方站了出来
to divulge a serious incident. During a private conversation in the prison yard, Sydney claimed that Colin had asked him, what do you think of my case? Sydney didn't know enough about it to offer any insight. Colin asked if Sydney could be trusted. Sydney assured him so. Colin then told Sydney about how he'd seen a distressed looking Alma walking through the eastern arcade. He tried to strike up a conversation with her but she ignored him. Colin told Alma that she didn't need to be afraid as he was the owner of the saloon. He encouraged her to come in and sit down. Alma followed Colin inside where the only other customers were seated out of view in the parlour. Certain that no one had seen them,
透露了一起严重事件。在监狱院子里的私人谈话中，悉尼声称科林问他，你觉得我的案子怎么样？悉尼对它了解不够，无法提供任何见解。科林问悉尼是否值得信任。悉尼向他保证。科林随后告诉悉尼他是如何看到一个看起来很痛苦的阿尔玛走过东拱廊的。他试图与她搭话，但她无视他。科林告诉阿尔玛，她不需要害怕，因为他是沙龙的老板。他鼓励她进来坐下。阿尔玛跟着科林进去，那里唯一的其他顾客坐在客厅里看不见的地方。确信没有人看到他们，
Colin led Alma into the private room behind the bar, closed the curtain, and offered her a drink of sweet wine. She refused at first, but Colin eventually persuaded her to take a sip. The two proceeded to talk for several hours, during which Alma consumed two more glasses of wine. At one point, Colin left to speak with another bar patron. After closing up shop, he returned to the back room to find that Alma had fallen asleep. Colin allegedly told Sydney Harding that he couldn't resist the temptation. He began molesting Alma, during which she stirred awake and cried out. Colin covered her mouth with his hand and proceeded to rape her. At some point during the attack, Alma fainted. Colin left the back room for a moment,
科林把阿尔玛带到吧台后面的私人房间，拉上帘子，给她倒了一杯甜酒。她起初拒绝，但科林最终说服她喝了一口。两人继续交谈了几个小时，期间阿尔玛又喝了两杯酒。有一次，科林离开去和另一位酒吧顾客交谈。关门后，他回到后屋，发现阿尔玛已经睡着了。据称科林告诉悉尼·哈丁，他无法抗拒诱惑。他开始猥亵阿尔玛，期间她惊醒并大叫。科林用手捂住她的嘴，继续强奸她。在袭击过程中的某个时刻，阿尔玛昏了过去。科林离开后屋片刻，
during which Alma regained consciousness and began crying out. He rushed back and tried to pacify her, but she wouldn't settle. Not knowing what came over him, he began choking her. Colin allegedly told Sydney that when he came back to his senses, he lifted Alma's arm and it flopped lifelessly, confirming she was dead. He calmed down and tried to think. Alma looked horrible and was bleeding badly. Colin grabbed a bucket full of water and cleaned her body, then the scene. He had plans to meet his friend Gladys at 9pm and he knew it'd be suspicious if he cancelled. He took Gladys to the saloon where she remained blissfully unaware that a child's body lay hidden just metres away. According to Sydney, Colin said he then walked
期间阿尔玛恢复了知觉并开始大叫。他冲回去试图安抚她，但她不肯平静下来。不知道自己怎么了，他开始掐她。据称科林告诉悉尼，当他恢复理智时，他抬起阿尔玛的手臂，它无力地垂下，证实她已经死了。他冷静下来，试图思考。阿尔玛看起来很可怕，流了很多血。科林抓起一桶水，清理了她的身体，然后清理了现场。他计划晚上9点见他的朋友格拉迪斯，他知道如果取消会很可疑。他带格拉迪斯去了沙龙，她一直幸福地不知道一个孩子的尸体就藏在几米远的地方。据悉尼说，科林说他随后陪
Gladys home and caught public transport back to his place in Footscray. Along the way, he made himself as conspicuous as possible to establish as many alibis as he could. In the early morning hours, Colin stole a bicycle from a neighbouring home and rode the 10 kilometres back to the Eastern Arcade. After walking around to the building to check that the coast was clear, he went inside the saloon. He stripped Alma's body naked and wrapped it in a coat before carrying her body across the road to Gunn Alley and leaving it there. On his way home, Colin stopped on Footscray Road and tore Alma's clothing into strips.
格拉迪斯回家，并乘坐公共交通工具回到他在富茨克雷的住处。一路上，他尽可能引人注目，以建立尽可能多的不在场证明。凌晨时分，科林从邻居家偷了一辆自行车，骑了10公里回到东拱廊。在绕着大楼走了一圈确认安全后，他进了沙龙。他剥光了阿尔玛的尸体，用一件外套包裹起来，然后把她的尸体搬过马路到冈恩巷，并把它留在那里。在回家的路上，科林在富茨克雷路停下来，把阿尔玛的衣服撕成碎片。
He scattered the pieces as he rode onwards, throwing each of her shoes into two nearby rivers. After returning the bicycle to his neighbour's house, he went home. Colin allegedly told Sydney that the only other person he'd told this to was his lawyer, who'd advised him to keep his mouth shut. He said he trusted Sydney and felt good about his case. Once it was all over, he intended to sue for compensation. Unless he lost, in which case he'd take his own life. The inquest into the death of Alma Turski took place on Wednesday January 25, a little under a month after she was killed. An angry mob encircled the building, forming the largest crowd the court had ever seen. This time, the police came prepared. They kept the peace as detectives, witnesses and members of Colin Ross's family were hurried inside,
他一边骑车一边散落碎片，把她的每只鞋子扔进两条附近的河流。在把自行车还给邻居家后，他回了家。据称科林告诉悉尼，他唯一告诉过的人是他的律师，律师建议他闭嘴。他说他信任悉尼，对自己的案子感觉良好。一旦一切结束，他打算起诉索赔。除非他输了，在这种情况下他会自杀。对阿尔玛·特斯基死亡的调查于1月25日星期三进行，距离她被杀不到一个月。一群愤怒的暴民包围了大楼，形成了法院有史以来见过的最大人群。这一次，警察做好了准备。当侦探、证人和科林·罗斯的家人被匆忙带入时，他们维持了秩序，
followed by the shackled man himself. Each of the case's witnesses took the stand to reiterate what they'd seen or heard. Colin stared unflinchingly as Ivy Matthews and Sydney Harding detailed the alleged confessions he'd made to them. Every so often his lips would curl into a smile. After hearing testimony from witnesses, case detectives, and a forensic analyst, Colin refused the opportunity to take the stand. The coroner then handed down their findings, concluding that Colin Ross was responsible for Alma Tursky's death and committing him to stand trial for her murder.
随后是戴着镣铐的他本人。案件的每一位证人都走上证人席，重申他们所见或所闻。当艾薇·马修斯和悉尼·哈丁详细说明他向他们做出的所谓供述时，科林面不改色地盯着。他的嘴唇不时弯成微笑。在听取了证人、案件侦探和法医分析师的证词后，科林拒绝了出庭作证的机会。验尸官随后宣布了他们的调查结果，结论是科林·罗斯应对阿尔玛·特斯基的死亡负责，并承诺将他送上谋杀罪审判。
In the meantime, a woman came forward to hand something over to police. She'd been travelling along Footscray Road when she came across a six-inch square piece of blue fabric in the gutter. The police believed it was part of the dress Elmatorski was wearing on the day she was murdered. The discovery added validity to the alleged confession that Colin Ross gave to his fellow inmate, Sydney Harding, and only strengthened the case against him. The trial commenced the following month in February. Having established itself as one of the most infamous criminal cases in Victoria's history, the courtroom was packed. Those who
与此同时，一名女子站出来将东西交给警方。她在沿着富茨克雷路行驶时，在排水沟里发现了一块六英寸见方的蓝色布料。警方认为这是埃尔玛·特斯基在被谋杀当天所穿裙子的一部分。这一发现增加了科林·罗斯向他的狱友悉尼·哈丁做出的所谓供述的有效性，并加强了针对他的案件。审判于次月即2月开始。由于已成为维多利亚州历史上最臭名昭著的刑事案件之一，法庭挤满了人。那些
missed out on a seat lingered outside the court, waiting for minute-by-minute updates. For Melburnians, the trial was just a formality. The general consensus was that Colin Ross was guilty. Colin was ushered into the courtroom, where he staunchly announced his declaration of not guilty. All the witnesses who testified at the coronial inquest reappeared for the murder trial. They more or less provided the same testimony, albeit with some additional details that filled in the blanks. The prosecution also presented two new witnesses, the first of whom was a man named Francis Upton. On Friday December 30 1921, Francis said he'd been drinking heavily at the Australian Wine Saloon.
错过了座位的人在法庭外徘徊，等待每分钟的更新。对于墨尔本人来说，审判只是一个形式。普遍的共识是科林·罗斯有罪。科林被带进法庭，在那里他坚定地宣布他不认罪。所有在验尸官调查中作证的证人都重新出现在谋杀案审判中。他们或多或少提供了相同的证词，尽管有一些额外的细节填补了空白。控方还提出了两名新证人，其中第一位是一个名叫弗朗西斯·厄普顿的人。1921年12月30日星期五，弗朗西斯说他在澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙喝了很多酒。
He ended up passing out in the nearby Flagstaff Gardens. Once he regained consciousness, it was a little after midnight and he was feeling sober. Wanting another drink, Francis headed back to the Australian Wine Saloon and noticed a light on inside. He approached the saloon and overheard a woman's voice say from within, oh my god, darling, how are we going to get rid of it? Francis tried the door. It was unlocked. He heard Colin Ross' panicked voice say, Ross' panicked voice say, "'There is somebody here.'" Colin then appeared at the door, clearly rattled. He held a small towel against one arm and his hands were stained red.
他最终在附近的弗拉格斯塔夫花园昏倒了。当他恢复知觉时，已经是午夜过后，他感觉清醒了。想再喝一杯，弗朗西斯回到澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙，注意到里面有灯光。他走近沙龙，听到里面传来一个女人的声音说，哦，天哪，亲爱的，我们该怎么处理它？弗朗西斯试了试门。门没锁。他听到科林·罗斯惊慌失措的声音说：“‘这里有人。’”科林随后出现在门口，显然很慌乱。他拿着一条小毛巾抵住一只手臂，双手染成了红色。
Francis asked him for wine. Colin rushed to the bar, grabbed a bottle and thrusted at Francis, pushing him away and retreating back into the saloon without asking for payment. Outside the arcade, Francis noticed the wine bottle had the same red staining on it as Colin's hands. The bottle was still sealed, leading Francis to suspect the staining wasn't wine, but perhaps blood. He took a swig from the bottle and left it on the corner of William and Flinders streets. The second new prosecution witness was Joseph Dunstan, another man who had been on remand with Colin Ross. Joseph testified that he was once reading a book in the prison yard when he saw Colin and Sydney Harding walking back and forth in deep conversation. Joseph overheard Colin saying
弗朗西斯向他要酒。科林冲向吧台，抓起一瓶酒，递给弗朗西斯，把他推开，然后退回沙龙，没有要求付款。在拱廊外，弗朗西斯注意到酒瓶上有和科林手上一样的红色污渍。瓶子仍然密封着，导致弗朗西斯怀疑污渍不是酒，而是血。他从瓶子里喝了一口，把它留在了威廉街和弗林德斯街的拐角处。第二位新的控方证人是约瑟夫·邓斯坦，另一名曾与科林·罗斯一起被还押的男子。约瑟夫作证说，他曾经在监狱院子里看书时，看到科林和悉尼·哈丁来回走动，进行深入交谈。约瑟夫无意中听到科林说
things like, I was talking to the girl. If they find a bike." Joseph heard Sydney ask, how was she dressed? This testimony further supported Sydney Harding's allegations that Colin had confessed to killing Alma Tursky. Primed by the press, the public viewed Colin Ross contentiously. Seemingly utterly unapologetic and unaffected in court, he chewed on lollies and joked with his lawyers during breaks. Whenever Colin was escorted through the angry mob, he shouted at them playfully, bye bye. Unlike at the Coronial Inquest, Colin opted to take the stand at his trial. He cut the figure of a gruff and angry thug. He denied all accusations levelled against him and repeated his unchanged
诸如，“我当时在和那个女孩说话。如果他们找到自行车。”约瑟夫听到悉尼问，她穿什么衣服？这一证词进一步支持了悉尼·哈丁关于科林承认杀害阿尔玛·特斯基的指控。在媒体的引导下，公众对科林·罗斯持怀疑态度。在法庭上看起来完全不后悔且不受影响，他在休息期间嚼着糖果并与律师开玩笑。每当科林被护送穿过愤怒的暴民时，他都会俏皮地对他们大喊，再见。与验尸官调查不同，科林选择在审判中出庭作证。他表现出一个粗鲁而愤怒的暴徒形象。他否认了针对他的所有指控，并重复了他未改变的
version of events. Colin said the police were trying to pin Elmer's murder on him as payback for the armed robbery case they lost against him years prior. The trial concluded on its fifth day. Collins sat composed and listened intently to the prosecution's closing remarks that described him as a desperate man facing a desperate charge and prepared to say anything desperate. The jury deliberated for a day before presenting their verdict, guilty. Colin stared blankly ahead as the announcement was made. Asked if he had anything to argue against receiving the death penalty, Colin responded, I still maintain that I am an innocent man and that my evidence is correct. If I am hanged, I will be hanged an innocent man. My life has been sworn away by desperate people. The judge sentenced Colin Ross to death by hanging. Colin reasserted his innocence several times over,
事件版本。科林说，警方试图将埃尔玛的谋杀案归咎于他，作为对他几年前赢得的武装抢劫案的报复。审判在第五天结束。科林坐着保持镇定，仔细听取了控方的结案陈词，控方将他描述为一个面临绝望指控的绝望男人，准备说任何绝望的话。陪审团审议了一天，然后宣布了他们的裁决，有罪。当宣布结果时，科林茫然地盯着前方。当被问及是否有任何理由反对接受死刑时，科林回答说，我仍然坚持我是无辜的，我的证据是正确的。如果我被绞死，我将作为一个无辜的人被绞死。我的生命被绝望的人发誓夺走了。法官判处科林·罗斯绞刑。科林多次重申他的清白，
but the judge interrupted him, saying, And may God have mercy on your soul. Outside court, the massive crowd erupted in cheers. For the first time, Colin appeared distraught and nearly collapsed as he was led to a waiting van. As he passed, the crowd yelled, scoundrel, serves you right, hanging's too good for you. The conviction heralded a celebration in Melbourne unlike any criminal trial in the history of the state. Colin endeavoured to appeal his conviction but was ultimately unsuccessful. He was sent to the gallows on Monday April 24 1922, almost four months after Alma Turski's murder. His final words were, I am now face to face with my Maker, and I swear by Almighty God that I
但法官打断了他，说：“愿上帝怜悯你的灵魂。”法庭外，巨大的人群爆发出欢呼声。科林第一次显得心烦意乱，在被带到等候的货车时几乎瘫倒。当他经过时，人群大喊，无赖，活该，绞死你都太便宜了。这一判决在墨尔本引发了一场庆祝活动，这在州历史上任何刑事审判中都是前所未有的。科林努力上诉他的定罪，但最终没有成功。他于1922年4月24日星期一被送上绞刑架，距离阿尔玛·特斯基被谋杀近四个月。他的遗言是，我现在面对我的造物主，我向上帝发誓，我
am an innocent man. I never committed the crime, and I don't know who did. I never confessed to anyone. I ask God to forgive those who have sworn my life away. To be continued next week. One quiet summer night in Melbourne 46 years ago, Suzanne Armstrong and Susan Bartlett were brutally stabbed to death in their home in Easy Street, Collingwood, as Suzanne's young toddler Layan is caught. Their killer has never been found, and their double homicide remains one of Australia's most chilling coal cases. It would be absolutely fair to say that I'm 75 now. Hardly a day goes by that I don't think about this particular murder.
是一个无辜的人。我从未犯下这起罪行，我不知道是谁干的。我从未向任何人供认。我请求上帝宽恕那些发誓夺走我生命的人。下周继续。46年前墨尔本一个安静的夏夜，苏珊·阿姆斯特朗和苏珊·巴特利在科林伍德易街的家中被残忍刺死，当时苏珊的幼儿拉扬被抓住了。她们的凶手从未被找到，她们的双重谋杀案仍然是澳大利亚最令人不寒而栗的悬案之一。完全可以说，我现在75岁了。几乎没有一天我不想到这起特殊的谋杀案。
Did they know their killer, or was it a random attack? At the time, police weren't sure and warned women in Melbourne to lock their doors and windows. Yet they failed to interview a number of witnesses living in the street. One right next door to Sue and Suzanne. She told me that she was sitting there at the window because it was a hot night and she said she saw a bloke leaving out the back gate. Until this day, until I die, I'm convinced there were two killers, not one. Has the investigation focused on the wrong person?
她们认识凶手吗，还是随机袭击？当时，警方不确定，并警告墨尔本的女性锁好门窗。然而，他们未能采访住在街上的多名证人。其中一个就在苏和苏珊隔壁。她告诉我，她当时坐在窗边，因为那是一个炎热的夜晚，她说她看到一个家伙从后门离开。直到今天，直到我死，我确信有两个凶手，而不是一个。调查是否集中在错误的人身上？
How many men were really there? In the Easy Street Murders, we'll talk to forensic and legal experts, as well as Suzanne and Susan's family and friends. She had a good sense of humour, and the kids loved her because she made them feel real. She wasn't constrained, I should say, by the norms of the time, which 45 years ago a single mother was regarded very poorly by society.
到底有多少人在那里？在易街谋杀案中，我们将与法医和法律专家，以及苏珊和苏珊的家人和朋友交谈。她很有幽默感，孩子们喜欢她，因为她让他们感到真实。她没有受到当时规范的约束，我应该说，45年前，单身母亲在社会上被看待得很差。
And the retired detective who'll never forget walking into the little house in Easy Street. This guy has done something so bad, so bad that you know humanity just would never even forgive him no matter who the relative was. What he did to those two girls could never ever ever be forgiven by anyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有那位永远不会忘记走进易街那座小房子的退休侦探。这家伙做了一些非常糟糕的事情，非常糟糕，以至于你知道人类永远不会原谅他，无论亲戚是谁。他对那两个女孩所做的事情，永远不会被任何人原谅。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。